- Hey guys, what's up?
We're here today to read some
of your comments and tweets.
Scroll through social media in real time.
So who knows what we're gonna find.
- It's a little bit of a roast battle.
- I mean, that is how
this whole show started,
you roasting me online.
- We're family.
It's our job to make fun of each other.
You know?
- That's a good point.
- So we've got the trailer here.
- I want you to be
exactly a version of you.
- A version of me.
- You, but with some tweaks.
- How does she even know
what you used to look like?
- That's what I was gonna
do, the same bit, man.
(Rob Lowe laughing)
It's just rich.
Is it cadence?
- Yeah, we have a similar
cadence and I think we have a lot
of the same sort of like phrasings-
- Right.
- Probably.
There's a photo of your
face still from the trailer
and I wrote underneath it,
I mean, that's just a simple pot shot.
Really, no more we need to go into that.
- That is really not
an even attempt to be-
- Funny, I know.
- Funny or kind.
- I know.
What is that, peach?
- It's a peach.
I think it's your butt.
- Oh God.
- Oh!
- Shmunguss?
- Shmunguss.
- What does that mean?
- I'm not well versed on shmunguss, but.
- Hey shmunguss.
- Okay.
If that means you're a shmunguss, I agree.
I don't know what that means.
Sounds like a nice woman, but
she might want to try therapy.
- People wanna participate
in the vitality of life.
- That is disturbing.
This is my personal favorite one so far.
- Oh, I'm sure it is.
- Nick wrote,
That's-
- We had a waiting room.
The Keebler Elf.
- A Kebleer elf, Justin Bieber circa 2009.
Haley Joel Osment five years ago.
- They all would've been great.
- So someone wrote,
- Dreamy.
- That's very good.
- This is a picture of
myself and the boys.
- Yep.
- Although someone has replaced
my head with John Stamos.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't see anything
wrong with this photo.
- It's clearly Stamos'
head, but not Stamos' body.
- Stamos, man.
Similar photo.
- Aww, look at how beautiful
every, the family is, Stamos.
- And he commented on this one.
- What did Johnny have to say for himself?
- He said, "That's rich."
It's a sweet photo.
John makes it better.
This next one, it's a photo
I posted on my Instagram
from your roast.
And immediately followed it up with
And you know what?
I don't think I did, and I'm sorry.
- There's you with no shirt.
That is a thirst trap, sir.
- Yeah, it might be.
- Under the guise of, it's
just me cooking up some eggs.
- [John Lowe] No, no, no, no, no.
- What?
Which mathematically
kind of makes some sense.
How did you know?
- True.
- Well it did.
- It did.
- In many ways, it did.
- In many ways.
I walked a mile in your
shoes today, Jackson.
I lived in the shadow of a God.
- Oh, nice.
You almost made it through a whole day
without comparing yourself to a God.
Unstable Season One, now
streaming only on Netflix.
And that makes me happy.